[Music]
hello and welcome to the greatest movie
ever podcast where we dissect our guests
favorite film in all its silver screen
cinematic scope this week I'm joined by
Adam Feldman he's a great battle rapper
and rapper that goes under the pseudonym
most prop he famously proposed you in a
rap battle which went viral he's written
numerous blogs across a range of
subjects and in general he's just an
all-around good guy he's here to discuss
the room how's it going at him hello
Paul very very nice to be here
and thank you for saying nice things
about about me that was nice and yeah
I'm I'm excited I like I like talking
about doing a lot and it was actually
going to be subjects and when
dissertation for film but then the guy
literally sitting next to me said it
before me and also there's barely
anything out there I can then make on it
because well for these reasons really
yeah yeah hello I must admit I hate this
film I hope it's good in an ironic way
but I would never put it on to enjoy
myself like a lot of exposure that I've
had to it through memes and YouTube
compilations so I'll start by asking why
do you enjoy it so much okay so yeah and
you know I am number no illusions this
is a terrible terrible movie like if
you're taking a face value it has almost
no merit as a film so I'm not you know
I'm not gonna sit here and pretend
ironically like it's you know an
absolute masterpiece but it's clearly
not the reason I love this movie and
I've been familiar with this movie now
for about a decade and the amount it's
one of those movies that is a shared
experience with friends it's it really
is if you're watching it on your writing
for the first time or if your exposure
to it is just so you know I'm scrolling
through Facebook and seeing like top 10
things that are wrong
the room kind of you know BuzzFeed
montage that it's just it you're not
gonna get the full experience of it and
I think because of that like communal
aspect of it and the kids in the actual
story behind how it came to be in who
told me was I was and what people don't
know about him and it's uh it just has
this mystique about it and no other fill
my house yeah I'm sorry there's it's
like a huge fun really and when I was
researching it I found like the still
midnight screenings going on for it
around the globe constantly like run for
so many years in LA and it's it has got
this massive phenomenon behind there
where people just they'll get a cinema
they'll invite 400 people or whatever
and just have a showing of the room and
everyone will be shouting out like
joining in with the movie all the famous
quotes and it is crazy how it has kind
of got this community to it because even
the best films of all time they kind of
struggle to get that sort of notoriety
where people will happily go along to
screenings just for the live experience
of it have you ever been to a screening
of it at all yes I've been to I think
three screenings at this point really
yeah yeah since I've been to in London
and one when it came down to Brighton
and I went to see a screening of the
disaster artist as well with not the
movie but the documentary okay breakfast
arrow who who's one of the co-stars in
the movie and yeah he didn't he was
there kind of giving a talk about it and
then yeah like there is it such so he
often turns up to these tips as well so
like maybe three talks in every 10
he'll be out just answering questions in
complete non sequiturs and just
just being Tommy was though about it and
I think that I don't I couldn't name you
any other movie that has had the kind of
low-key cultural impact that the
greenhouse and is such an immediate
connector between people like if you're
either you watch them together and it's
some things you then quote backing each
other forever my marriage has at least
one line from the river they each day
and that's not that's more an
exaggeration like a hundred percent you
know and if you meet someone else is
already extinct however you're instantly
friends yeah you get along it's like
that alright there's a lot like battle
rap like you know if you mentioned you
mentioned Petra to someone who's
familiar with new Tetris like it
instantly like oh yeah how fast for
pressure a like you know I mean I know
that's going to mean much to preggers
eight means a lot to me because I did
about three run through minutes and
they're exactly that shared experience
that so do you remember the first time
you saw it
yes I do so I was at I was at uni in
Sussex I went down the corner shop
Covanta to promote that I knew off hand
and he was telling me about this room
that is just this film this weird
vampiric Belgian guy there's your me
he's not Belgium but that's what he said
at the time and I was like and it's just
terrible and it's just people walking in
and out of room saying stuff really
badly and you know I'm a stick that [ __ ]
stuff anyway you know it's it's just a
fact back then I was looking for
ironic appeal and obviously I found it
in space with this movie yeah and I sat
down with three or four friends from uni
and just got drunk and we watch this
movie and we were just howling all the
way for exempt from the first life in
the moment tommy was low opened his
mouth
we just we we were just laughing we
watched it again the next day and then
you know it really was it's just this
this journey through like this film
can't get any worse and then it flies
away and then it finds away to play it
again you just you feel kind of like sad
when it's our ball yeah that journey
when you go through a like four or five
people that close to you is is yeah you
can't really repeat that definitely now
normally I sort of do these episodes as
a sort of recap and we go through things
and analyze them but you've seen it a
lot more than I have I've probably
watched it about three times in total so
I kind of want to treat this episode as
like a quiz instead of just bashing the
movie non-stop so I'll be throwing
questions your way on things I didn't
understand and many fans of my YouTube
know I like to do end and explained
videos so I'll be probably stealing all
over your words and do Lorne on this but
let's start off what the hell is the
movie about Adam Wright picked up some
plot points but then some of them that
just seemed to go no like there's a gun
subplot and some of them just that
there's like a bit where they talk about
some guy pissing his pants or something
they're just kind of gone lost of it
there's a there's a breast-cancer
surplus and that claudette the mother
has breast cancer but she never never
really had nothing happens with that
what is a movie about about I think is
the so there's two answers to this
they'll ask you a few answers for this
right it's not a deep and meaningful
movie in of itself he didn't know what
the hell he was doing
and so but I mean the general thread is
like the story is actually pretty basic
the story at face level his just guys
best friend and cheats on his auto his
bird cheating on his best friend on him
with his best friend and then he
sad he kills himself is that like that
that in terms of the story that's in in
terms of the things he's exploring I
think for he was kind of any included
meaning like imagine in the guy that
you're looking at with the strike of the
air and the weird ruby place you've got
to imagine him slumped over a typewriter
and think like he's literally store I'm
gonna make a film to try and validate
myself because no one no one wants
anything to do with me creatively so I'm
gonna do this for myself and I'm going
to try man every single issue I think is
important so you know he said you know
think all counts the powerful thing I'll
put that in there obviously it goes
nowhere because there was just he just
wasn't planning ever planning to take
those things anyway he just wanted to
give them a shout out the problem is he
gave them a shout out in terms of like
things happening main characters
immunity pastor artistic accounted in
the book as well the actors the place
called it kind of questions it like
right my carrot has breast cancer but I
don't he's disabled mentioned again to
just come back like he's like nervous a
twist
yeah there's quite a lot of those
moments in the film and then one of the
biggest questions for me was what does
the title mean the room what does it
actually mean like I don't know yeah cuz
I thought I found an answer from Tommy
was oh but I don't know if it's actually
this was reported as something he'd said
it was because many things can happen in
a room some bad some good but I don't
feel like that's someone's made that up
I think but I don't know
so what no idea like if you find imagine
insane like there is no nothing too
weird or stupid for him to say yeah
so what do you think of Tommy was old as
a person why I know I don't at the end
of the day I've seen his other stuff as
well I've seen the neighbors yeah which
is a sitcom that he made after the room
after he'd been told by everyone they
found him funny it is I did like I've
seen the room 37 times where I sat
through three quarters one half-hour
episode of the neighbors and I could
have finished it yeah I heard that they
tried to like kind of recapture it but
it was him intentionally trying to be
funny so it sort of lost its appeal
it was quite crunchy and it was really
racist and sexist as well and I didn't
get like you know you hear and read a
lot and it's in the disaster I saw the
new t2 as well he was trying to horrible
to lessor onset like yeah well
humiliated her for a body and stuff like
don't actually think he's a good person
like this the agreement that the brute
being one of one of my favorite movies
is not me saying that Swimming's Oh is
someone I respect as a nice because
everyone approach to me in the beginning
through laughing at it yeah and I think
there was a lot about the actual story
at the film specific he liked the film
has a personality of its own at this
point yeah and I feel like Tommy was
always kind of been given life by that
and he's feeding off it but it's it's a
separate entity to him at this point and
I think don't worry that that came to be
was quite admirable overshare just the
sheer knuckleheaded determination and
self or the belief just quite not having
a [ __ ] clue what you're doing it's
like that's that's like an impressive
level of delusion and that is yeah
creates and you create as well like that
develop dedication and propping it to
one side and losing heart is by I
actually I respect
part of how it came to be yeah he's sort
of completely like not self-aware and
it's sort of baffling how he just
doesn't get how bad it is like the
disaster artist goes into it quite a bit
but I think the enigma that surrounds
him sort of added a lot of the mystique
to this apparently he made his fortune
selling coats and in the disaster artist
book he's described as having a
bottomless bank account so it's kind of
strange that he had all these resources
behind them but we've never had like a
clear answer like no one really knows
his age where he's from in this like
movie you could say it's their hero you
could say he's 50 you know you just
can't tell
and and Tommy from my research you
wanted to make like an oscar movie and
it kind of makes you think when you're
watching it is there a checklist to
making Oscar films that Tommy tried to
exploit and in doing yeah and he sort of
parried as parodies them a bit like we
have suicide emotional performances sex
scenes betrayal it's all very dramatic
on the page but I think the acting so
bad that becomes laughable and even in
making the movie made some really weird
choices like you brought two types of
camera and shot on digital and film
which is really weird
you also paid for the cameras instead of
just renting them and the stuff you read
about on me sort of like an idiot but I
don't know if he's an idiot or if he's a
genius because he's made so much money
off this like Annie
he's obviously good with money because
he he owns a lot a real estate and he
was quite wealthy before making the room
and it is kind of this how does this guy
get by like mystery that surrounds them
because you can't imagine anyone hiring
him to do a normal job so he was
destined to sort of be in the room but
I've asked what the what the movies
about I've got the plot of the movie and
so I'll read that out for the
who might have watched the room so
Johnny's a successful banker who lives
in San Francisco with his fiancee Lisa
is that he showers her with dollars with
gifts and sex in the belly button which
is still not satisfied
she seduces his best friend mark and the
two begin a secret affair meanwhile
Johnny having overheard Lisa confessor
infidelity to him whether called heir
attaches a tape recorder to their phone
in an attempt to identify another Danny
a neighboring college student that
Johnny financially and emotionally
supports has a run-in with an armed drug
dealer called Chris aw I'm just gonna
skip that plot point cuz it doesn't
really go anywhere Danny also Lutz lusts
after Lisa and confesses this to Johnny
who understands and encourages him to
instead pursue one of his classmates
from school
Johnny spirals into a mental haze and
calls upon Pierre his and Mark's friend
and the psychologist for help basically
we just have an affair there's a
surprise birthday party and one of his
friends catches Lisa kissing mark while
the other guests are outside and
confronts them about the affair
johnny announces that Lisa he and Lisa
are expecting a child now this was a
really weird thing I got caught yeah
because I'm sure he mentions that
they've been expecting it for 18 months
or something but yeah that's not
pregnancy works really and it's one of
the shaming you thought I mean it wasn't
safe throughout my whole whole movie
just how detached from human
conversation he is yeah there's like you
can sort of tell that this very well the
plot finishes basically Johnny finds out
and kills himself but back to that point
you were saying there's lots of strange
and weird idioms that he comes out with
and other characters do that make you
realize that the script doesn't sell
was written by someone who English was
the first language like two's great but
three's a crowd instead of two's company
three's a crowd
chocolate is the symbol of love leave
your stupid comments in your pocket okay
maybe here's a saying then but it's just
weird and even like they loop over each
other's lines and the dubbing so off
it's just crazy that like Tommy thought
this was good I just I just don't get
Adam in the I've got the original
scripts before editing okay and this is
before logic was applied so did the film
that you're seeing is after a script
suit of where's that light being this
Chris is just a collection of sentence
since basically some one of them is Lisa
brings breakfast down to mark and says
here's your coffee and English muffin
and in your mouth yeah and it's just
like the thing is he so he just wanted
to make a movie oh yeah he had no you
know training he didn't know what he was
doing he literally only made a movie if
you wanted to be in a movie because no
one else would put him in a movie
because he was terrible and so as part
of that that's quite like he had known
it's almost like he improvised the whole
script like he just sat there having
types and it was by yeah everything he
was thinking at the time just went in
from almost like this weird
stream-of-consciousness thing and not
even like a baby flinch way where it's
always but it's like you can sort of
seen a string of thoughts that's going
on behind it and then yeah
it'll just come out and he's really
gobble ways because he's just he's not
only you know getting by in a language
that clearly isn't his own machinee he
always tells people he's from New
Orleans he doesn't hear his accent he
doesn't peek out like I genuinely think
he has had some kind of head injury and
it's not like apologizes his weirdness
just like I love lent you weird people
I don't plenty people to you know
communicate maybe to the L side world
there's nothing wrong with them they're
just weird there is there is something
like Disney retain jurisdiction or about
in and I think the weird barbels sort of
idiom speak yeah it's a symptom of a
second language but also he doesn't know
it's the second language so he genuinely
just hears this stuff and thinks it's
what people say yeah and I don't know I
just turns of phrase but there lot of
things that are slightly wrong you know
that's why I read your your Twitter a
lot because you do a lot of like dirt
speak and whatever I love all that so
like when when this is coming up it's
almost like if it to me and had written
that on purpose for like a for at like
character it would be hilarious
yeah definitely yeah I can totally see
the appeal in that and you are like it
is very clear that there is one vision
behind this like he's doing the script
the directing the editing what happens
is like this is an example of when full
creative controls given to someone who
doesn't really know what they're doing
like there's people like Stanley Kubrick
who could easily write the script
director edit it but Tommy was always
just not accepting that like apparently
he fired the whole crew originally fired
quail I read somewhere that the guy who
plays Marc am Greg he wasn't the
original actor and you know fired and
there was reports that actors even tried
every word line so they made sense but
Tommy would catch them and tell them to
do what he'd written and it's sort of a
very domineering
view of the project to its detriment but
in a way it makes it better because if
this was just a mediocre movie you
wouldn't have the reputation that it
does not so and I think when I say
actually with the marketing as well he
didn't just have like replaced the
original mark he was filming director
stero scenes in the secret so he was he
was filming took a scene with the old
mark and then he he was amazing the
editing a secret movie with Greg Sestero
him yes like the guy that was the
domineering set stuff I Michael you know
you seen the professor right and you
read about it as well like it's he
created a horrible atmosphere and saved
unsafe you know I mean ridiculously hot
with no war it was kind of an [ __ ]
director as in a complete [ __ ]
director Lapointe
um you know he really didn't know what
he was doing but it's almost like by the
people now what must be getting mad
royalties from the room anyways so
they've been they now won't regret their
experience in it but yeah and the actual
is one of those experiments that would
have had to happen like by some person
who too much money and too much time on
their hands and a warped sense of humor
like giving money to someone they knew
could it make a movie and asking them to
make a movies like that it's the kind of
thing that would have had to be an
active choice somewhere down the line
but because it happens just organically
even it's just some guy who had loads of
money and decided to do it himself it's
like an experiment that says self up and
no one needed to actually kind of
engineer a situation they didn't have to
happen obviously if I'm talking about
someone solving that having all that
power it doesn't that's already happen
why the means that it did for the group
yeah this is so like a really weird
surreal element to it as well to me is
one of the other reasons that's so
popular
like unnoticed today like when he's on
and this is the first time I noticed a
boy it's it's once you see it it's
completely obvious like when he walks
out he does oh hi mark the the shed bit
that he walks out of it it's literally
on the edge of the roof so there's no
way that you could go up the stairs in
there like that that room couldn't have
a staircase in it and it feels very sort
of there's a lot of overly manufactured
sections like the green screen
backgrounds where they've clearly spent
a lot of time and some of the sets
themselves but there's no sort of
thought process to it that they don't
use makeup on on them sets which like if
people don't know like skin tones just
don't look good on film
you have to use makeup a lot of the time
in the sorbets an attention to detail
that is really missing from it and it
makes the movie itself sort of have this
weird atmosphere to are almost the sort
of something above it like when we were
doing the shining for early earlier in
this podcast I saw so I've noticed with
that film that things just don't seem
right and out there's like a slight out
of place thing about them like a lot of
the rooms in the shining if you were to
draw a map of the hotel from above the
rooms couldn't exist because they saw
overlap each other and go around corners
and there's a lot of that in this movie
and it sort of makes I don't know the
like have you seen hereditary I read it
reads like a horror movie where this
sort of like sort of overtone of things
going wrong and and I sort of feel that
in this movie as well when I'm watching
it this sort of a sense over the top of
it that
there's something heading hidden in the
subtext that makes it really unnerving
like Danny the relationship that he has
with Johnny it's really weird and
strange and sort of and those are the
things like timewise
it all seems kind of off of there's one
day in the film we're about 70 different
things happen in the one day and none of
those things could happen in that time
scale but they just keep happening and
happening and happening the scene on top
of scene and I thought it's just really
weird watching it like you do get this
feeling like yeah there's something this
is like hell but people just don't
realize they're in hell it's just a
never-ending day of nightmares yeah in
his tool shed when the best theories
heard is that Denny is actually a catch
right okay if I don't like obviously
every watched it since and like yeah
because if you just forget he's talking
and what what he's actually doing the
way he's sitting were like jumping on
the bed with them and [ __ ] like yeah
convincingly could be just Tommy with
those interpretation they were [ __ ]
cat like yeah someone like David Lynch
or Charlie Kaufman made this maybe on
purpose frame to frame exactly the same
performances script everything the same
but how Charlie Kaufman's may want it
instead of Tommy Rizzo it would be total
work of surreal subversive genius the
people would be trying to read into it
the only difference is that these
decisions weren't illiterate so it's a
complete [ __ ] and but they're
there so there is so much that's wrong
with the room with with every throat
like they're there those pictures of
spoons yeah you can almost like he
thought that there's a lot of like oh
the audience won't know that like when
you read in the disaster right it's like
the audience
felt like they stupid so it's basically
him telling the audience they're stupid
and sort of like showing up not
obviously not consciously but in doing
that in making a film where he is
literally as the sole creator of the
film thought people are so stupid that I
don't I can just have pictures of spoons
in the background yeah and everyone in
the movie is so stupid and he's pretty
stupid and it's just this like massive
expose of just like compounding idiocy
that is just because of the way this
movie damn your life it just makes the
story that much more stupid and like
it's kind of having the audience for
laughing at themselves way like you used
to work on easy and I think that's
actually really appropriate because it
is like weird friction with like we're
laughing at this guy but we're having a
good time like what's like like it's all
of that friction at once and like you
say uneasy and I think that is
absolutely the right approach because I
think storytelling should be uneasy and
often it's quite you know very in
structure by leading me through this
emotion and that emotion and this is how
I'm making me feel uneasy and cranking
up the tension and whatever but because
because it's the way the story behind
the room and because it's essentially
one of these different types of idiocy
so I'm rubbing up against each other
creating a really unique kind of tension
that you just I don't think you getting
any other filming on purpose or by
accident yeah and that tension it
doesn't provide the story cuz the
story's pointless but it's part of
driving that friction and that tension
where you've got like Tommy was low
didn't mean to make this movie but I'm
having such a good time but I'm laughing
at him but he's terrible
but yeah so you've got all of these
different like intentions they're going
to get had it and it's like that
friction is create a very different way
for any other movie I've seen definitely
haven't there's weird thing about it is
there's quite a lot of sex scenes in it
and these off when you watch like your
top 10 weirdest things about the room
these don't really get put
there but there's so many early on and
it's kind of creepy
like Lisa seduces Mark at some point and
the music's really weird and it's just I
don't know it's sort of like a nightmare
like even the couple who want to have
sex in their apartment and it just seems
like sex is put in there for the sake of
it I could pass it off as a softcore
porno at points like the whole belly
button thing famously where Johnny sort
of humming a belly button
it's just really weird I think so this
all goes back to imagining him home
stays with sighs Maria I think he like
bought like three books on how I'll make
a film like I know how the write a story
Howard director film and how to sell a
film I feel like he's got those three
guide books and sat down and for how do
I get these as the monthly as possible
into this movie without making it seem
stupid obviously he didn't know that
what he was making the stupid but seeing
the sex scenes almost feel like he read
a thing that said you know I need the
sex to sell this movie and here you go
five minutes of it within the first
seven yeah so it it's part of that I
mean it's terrible and the fact that he
had to use one of the scenes twice as
well yeah it's like this that's bad to
me is one of the meta moment sort of
thing the mess of things about the movie
where it's like you're not watching the
movie you're watching a guy go is
anything there so how do I make it look
like she didn't want to have said chick
me again yeah just the like that the
mole in the aspect of just just is
strangely oh man thinking this up and
it's I know it's like the obvious sad
downside of a is that the actress Juliet
Danielle just had a horrible Simon set
yeah you know it was it was really bad
that's part of as well I'm really
uncomfortable with about for me was his
his attitude to women and
and also the complete lack of anyone
there isn't boy in the movie it like
there's weird elements to his
personality though I'm just I wouldn't
hang around with someone like him if you
know the sex scenes apart that and I
also think they feed this kind of weird
narrative behind the movie without even
really having this say anything like you
didn't you didn't need to read anything
about the disaster eyes to know exactly
why those scenes were so awkward yeah it
sort of reminds me a bit of Bioshock a
bit like this world is sort of Tommy's
like utopia but it's just so so it's
like even when he walks into the flower
shop and the owners like I didn't
recognize you and this guy looks like he
looks like Michael Jackson cross with
Slenderman and there's no way in hell
now you wouldn't see him a mile off and
but it's like hi doggy you're my
favorite customer it just so really
weird it's like everyone's like on drugs
like what the perfect world and tell me
what those eyes would be like yeah it's
just really women are really portrayed
badly in this light there's no like
Claudette who's the manipulative mother
Tilly search she's really weird she
wants Lisa to marry Johnny
but she's just a piece of [ __ ] really
and she makes that these grand
statements but they're also a very
shallow like the breast cancer thing she
serves like the way she delivers the oh
I've got breast cancer she doesn't even
seem lectures that bothered that she has
breast cancer she just kind of drops it
in like oh I had a quiche for lunch it's
really weird and Lisa wants to have an
affair one second but then she loves
Johnny the next and I just I just so got
it I don't know what's happening at
screenings when when Lisa said anything
like women changed their mind all the
time
the whole audience shouts out it's cause
you're a woman everyone is aware of the
treatment and women of this movie but
almost like a kind of narrow-minded if
he yeah so Lisa's termination and like
because of the lack of talent it's like
this let me say he's built this utopia
for himself and it's like a few inside
the head of someone where all of my
husband himself it's led the Malkovich
Malkovich world in Being John Malkovich
like you know he's got its perfect world
but everyone loves them and you know
women don't really matter or in
everyone's way and it's like that's why
it's uncomfortable or be there but it's
just that unfiltered view inside this
like kind of bigoted guys heads em it's
like this way it's uncomfortable and
like you know and I even feel
uncomfortable saying I'm as fond of the
movie as I am but yes every everyone
like because of that ironic distance
that you have from it from beginning it
feels safe to enjoy watching it I feel
really invested in the story you'd be
like hang on a second
and why actually a massive woman-hating
racist yeah laughing at how bad it is
misogyny and kind of lack of diversity
sort of audience about laughing at this
when you actually you start to look at
the human parts of him like the
determination and the actual you know
the the fact that he's lonely well I'm
not surprised that he's lonely really
yeah it doesn't get better like I just
love that we're getting unfiltered view
like not times at the studio I'm not
handle did anyone that would make it
make any sense into just the head of
some weather we never want to me yeah
definitely and Lisa saw is the villain
of the piece really like she gets drunk
no she gets Johnny drugged sorry on what
does he drink say somewhere is it a hot
chocolate whiskey
yeah it's really really weird like
something you would never drink but
anyway so she gets him drunk and then
frames him for hitting her but why did
she need a get him drunk
just to say that he hit her like anyway
would know he didn't hit her anyway
because he did not
sorry that's my Tommy who was all
impression for the pod the podcast
everyone's got one
but anyway mark tells he goes up to the
roof and mark tells him this story about
this girl that got beat up and he just
laughs about it and goes wow what a
story and then he goes I'm so I'm so
lucky to have you as my best friend and
I love Lisa so much and it's this
constant jumping back and forth between
character emotions that I think just
it's so jarring and it's it is crazy
that no one stepped in and just said
look stop this [ __ ] it's weird and then
to make it even weirder Danny comes up
and he just wants to play football 24/7
oh yeah yeah and he talks about love and
Lisa and Jonny's explaining how she
loves him back but it's like if he was
suspecting his future wife as he calls
her of cheating on someone cheating with
someone
why isn't Denny like the first in the
firing line when he's coming up in that
min that he loves her and you you would
think that that's like you think they
would all come to a head and that would
be like a plot point where Johnny starts
to suspect Danny and they they lose
their friendship because of it and then
he finds out it's mark but it just
doesn't really go anywhere I mean the
weirdest character in it
you feel so he's in a different movie
completely to everyone else
you saw I've got this whole
he's in love with Johnny and in love
with Lisa he's like the third person in
their relationship and yeah I just I
just don't get it
Bobby's he's almost dead because there
is no one else in the movie that Johnny
could realistically show that he's
actually a nice person that you can show
that you're a someone's a good partner
in a movie or romantic or whatever but
you know they it's trying to show that
like in this weird little Tommy Wiseau
utopia
not only does everyone loved him he
actually deserves it as well Denny could
he's funding Denny's way through college
and doing they make so many points of
like you know always paying him through
college always like his dad
oh he's you know they're like well more
and more and it's like then he has this
little tote and Johnny and therefore
Tommy with those overriding goodness and
which is why he doesn't make much sense
as a character because he was never for
others of character the drug thing makes
absolutely no sense yeah you know it
certainly is very little of - he happens
to or as a result of Denny that will
have any impact on the movie the only
the only bit he's in that really matters
is when he's upset because Johnny's dead
but again he's caught like he's just
there to show the people would be upset
if Johnny's clash tommy was what they're
why this whole movie just feels like a
cry for help yeah did right here's a
theory foot does Mark have superpowers
because very busy yeah and there's that
guy who they're chucking the football
about and Mark barely touches him when
he's talking about underwear and he goes
flying in the bins like goes flying
across the room it's like why were
unwilling that he's got one hell of a
temper because he nearly throws that guy
off the building when he's accused of
having an affair with Lisa what do you
think of Mark in the story because I
know everyone tends to talk about John
and Tommy but what about mark what are
his dreams did does mark have dreams I
don't even know what his job is
yes I've seen it 38 times I couldn't
tell you what marks about often looking
hunky and the hating women who then get
beat up and put in hospital Juan
Guerrero Street yeah I don't like again
like I don't really know what any
character in this movie once
I don't think tommy was only knows what
people want and I think he's like he
comes you know he's very paranoid and
you read a lot and you stay in
interviews as well isn't like being
asked about himself he doesn't he
doesn't know what people want so none of
these characters want anything they're
just they're sort of milling around
mark mark still if they spike I don't
know he's not got superpowers like they
were like tommy was always talking about
having vampires in the movie at one
point well no I don't know if that's
like a little aftershock of that where
they took out the squid but I honestly
think that Tommy was like right we have
to have an amusing scene now they're
talking about wonder underwear which is
intrinsically funny as we all know so
they're like you know this conversation
get that man it's quite old it's
embarrassing stories and more people and
Tommy was I didn't really know how it
works about that scene into a punch line
saying he had to have someone falling
over but there wasn't really a reason to
have someone fall over he just kind of
needed the scene said yeah so just
barely touches him and then he goes
flying and then he picks them up and
they leave there's no discernible reason
what happens yeah and then they got the
tuxedos the lovely tuxedo see ya
and they decide to go play football in
them for some reason I don't I I don't
know what what what the hell's going on
and weren't there so the accountant is
it
psychiatrist or someone he's got glasses
so easy he's got a good job anyway and
he falls over they all kind of pile on
in a quite at home heroic way and then
they have this gathering to announce the
big the big baby and another thing like
Tommy's with Johnny the Tommy and Johnny
are the same person anyway but he's had
this type of Lisa cheating for a while
but he hasn't listened to it for
confirmation till now yeah so anyway
finds oh and he kills himself at the end
and like I think by like xx viewing or
something he sort of learn to step back
and look it's just a guy like imagine
right in a battle right and you're
trying to do like 50 different angles or
whatever and you're like trying to say
everything but like when you're in an
experienced battle you don't really know
how to register down see well I mean you
did but you were actually good when it's
like and it's like that it's like these
loose ends that kind of aren't fulfilled
and it's just it I don't know it's so
it's just an exterior that's part one of
the maddening parts of the movie and I
think if there were like 30% of them it
would just mean the movie wasn't
enjoyable labyrinth of lost ends it's
like it's just each what if each one
becomes a better joke as it goes along
yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah it is sort of
this quite I know we kind of have went
off a bit and got quite dark on it but
it is quite a fun film to watch and I
can imagine with people III didn't watch
it with anyone but I just sort of every
couple of minutes like her and just sort
of them shaking my head a bit with a
smile on my face
um but this ending it it's very dark it
reminds me of what we used to do
before a school play when we said to our
final project in drama at school
everyone's project was about someone
cheating and then someone committing
suicide and so he puts the gun in his
mouth bang he falls back ELISA
runs up and asks if he's dead which is
like yeah he just shot himself in the
head
she then I don't really get this dynamic
like she wants to she saw it says to
mark he's dead when we can be together
but she's also devastated that he's dead
and then marked as the famous get out of
my life you [ __ ]
Danny runs in they go he's in a better
place days is so sad
and then the police sirens go off and
it's the end yeah what are your final
thoughts on the film well it's like I am
literally about to sit down with one of
my colleagues from work and introduce
them to the room yeah first time light
is something it will always be for me a
way of like gauging someone sense of
humor and like yeah like as you say
we've got pretty dark on it and like
yeah kinda wish we'd went more fun with
it and be honest but yeah those things I
know I mean like I love it but like
again it's the page 38 playing tonight
like I'm kind of past the point in
seeing as this like haha this boy made a
[ __ ] think there's so much [ __ ] slip up
out there right any film could any at
any fly and replaced that as the worst
movie of all time if they wanted to why
it's like you still about to step back
and and like appreciate why this
happened but they're so rare that like
so many strangers pull together over
something so relentlessly relentlessly
[ __ ] stupid and misguided but yeah
and it's
I'll tell you what watching the disaster
is kind of stare at Peter Cole mostly
because I've always been like maybe
stuff like I'm not I'm better now but
like I've always like made stuff has
been deliberately [ __ ] because I found
it funny yeah buddy it actually made me
like think it's voice about what it is
to make something good or bad like
what's behind it like it and I think if
you make something with sincerity that's
just that's all that can be asked and
this film was made with like 400%
sincerity he wanted this film to exist
so bad it just feels wrong to begrudge
him it you know no it's it will it will
always be like something I left we were
friends but yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry it
wasn't this whimsical which you expected
okay appreciate it reflective on it
though you liked it did Joe genuinely
get feels at the end of that movie yeah
but I think it works great as a piece of
what not to do like literally everything
in it you could take to a film student
we right right don't do this don't do
this and it's gonna massively influence
their decisions in the future obviously
it's got a huge following and is an
attaining it's just so baffling how it
got made it's a it really is like a once
in a blue moon film that just had so
many bad things come together to make it
this masterpiece and the world is
probably a better place for it I think I
wouldn't know approximately 80% of my
friends group its words in the ring by
honestly from the last 10 years
most to I ever had to watch the read at
some point or had already seen it like
it's just that movie but that's what I
mean that's why it still does midnight
screenings but there is no independent
truly independent film that has made as
much back Ottomans investment right yeah
than to pure financial success why hiss
Bobby like you've got a look at that as
one of the best successes of all time as
well even I wasn't quite
traditional means or because it did it
on their it it's still kind of like half
of that I respect that a lot so it's I'm
just looking now to see how much the
rooms gross in total there's lots of
different and Hort
they have final figures they still don't
know yeah this roughly said anywhere
between seven million and thirty million
dollars which is good so it's it's
definitely made Tommy who financed it
all more of a multi-millionaire than he
already was so you know it just goes to
show sometimes when you go after your
dreams if you persistent and you put
your heart into it they can come true
that is literally it like that I know
that's a really like cheesy thing to say
but that is initially what happened and
like he doesn't he's not like some super
gifted kids or you know he is literally
an idiot yeah an idiot with money or
like the other morold story is be an
idiot with money and then you can do
pretty much wherever you want yeah which
is always a nice thing to end on it's a
metal of hope by everyone view is back
in your pocket and warmed them exactly
so before we say goodbye to have
anything you want to promote and get
people to check out yes please these
guys can go to Salman Khan camp calm
that's where all my music lives I've got
a new album drop in on the 29th of
November and it's got people like
Professor elemental on it and Adam the
rapper and they're they're good at
rapping and I've got battle with O'Shea
dropping very soon as well so watch out
for that and yeah gone what's the room
with some friends preferably drunk and
yeah and yeah I don't have any friends
so I can't I can't do that but thanks
for stopping by and make sure you
subscribe listeners our next
episode right we're going to be covering
the thing with Theo came from slime
house TV it's one of my favorite movies
so definitely keep an eye out for it and
thanks again Adam I've been speaking to
you and I've grown a new appreciation
yeah I've grown a new appreciation for
this phone and I hope the listeners have
- um so I'll see you around
take care much love goodbye goodbye